Schreckensbilder aus China aus der
Millionenstadt Chongqing der komplette
Corona Schrecken in diesem Video hier ja
sehen sie dort mitten in der Nacht
stehen tausende zehntausende
hunderttausende Menschen in einer
Schlange und der Grund ist die
corona-warn-app der hat sich auf Orange
gestellt haben sie bekommen auf ihrem
Handy und das einzige wie sie es wieder
grün bekommen damit auch Freiheiten und
überhaupt Mobilität und Flexibilität in
ihrem Alltag ist dass sie sich testen
und genau das machen diese Menschen und
sei es dass es die ganze Nacht dauert ja
das ist eine mega Menschenschlange eine
Schlange der corona-diktatur in China
Menschen die für ihre restfreiheit
Stunden Stunden anstehen müssen weil die
Behörden mit einem Klick ihre
corona-ampel auf Orange gestaltet haben
unglaublich
[Musik]